dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
日本語アドバイス第3回開始
1年間日本に行きます何か持って行くべきものってありますか
あるオールドスパイスピーナッツバターそして大きすぎない機体
半年で牛緒に話せるようになる事って
可能ですか無理だ
フューチャーの定義を教えてください日本語の勉強を始めて1年経っていますがまだ
話し自信がありませんどうしたらいいですか
アニメは見てみた日本人怒の最も気まずい経験を教えてください
留学時代に皮膚科に電話して袋じゃなくてもぐらが心配だと伝えたときなぜか動物病院
じゃないと言われた
オーディオブックを聴くと眠くなったり違う事を考え出したりします
どうしたらいいなとは刺激を受けすぎて本を楽しむことができなくなっ
ているしばらくインターネットを使わないことを勧める
なお村上春樹以外の小説家選んでみるのもアリ
恋愛に役立つ言葉を教えてください僕の後についていなさい
アイス買ってきたよ
昨日は悪かったなぁ
ネットフリックスでなんか見る好きなや口言葉を教えてください
akira 映画音楽のレクイエムフォーサーズカッター perjantai
日本語の授業を受けるお金がないので今は独学をしています
独学をする人へのアドバイスってありますか
そうだな独学を続けること授業のほとんどはお金の無駄が学費の30万円です
ありがとうございますそれでは2000円の教科書を上げます
えっネイティブじゃ
ない人がいっぱいいる教室もご利用いただけますちゃったーーーー
日本語がまったくできない白磁の友達が東京オリンピックにいくって言っています
彼に伝えるべきアドバイスをお願いします2020年の東京オリンピックね
アドバイスをしては鉄を避けること
[音楽]
ni
me